hello everybody this is
peter cooper from the ncbi uh welcome to
today's webinar
today's webinar is about how to find
data for your research organism meaning
your non-model organism
adelaide rhodes is going to be our
presenter today so let's go ahead and
get started and i'm going to turn it
over to adelaide
now to start presenting take it away
adelaide
okay thank you peter uh so
i'm a recent addition to
ncbi and i come from a background of
studying
uh marine crustaceans in that are uh
found in the benthic zone in the ocean
so down in the mud and there isn't a lot
of
genomic information about them so i
started wondering how can i get the best
information on a
research organism that isn't a model
organism i thought that might be
useful information to talk about today
so what we're going to cover today is
just
a basic introduction to
the entry points to searching
at ncbi there's more than one place you
can go to find data
and then the second thing we're going to
do is a demonstration
on a well annotated organism a whale
whales and looking at a specific gene
and then we're going to run through a
few exercises such as
finding sequences making a set of
primers
and then finding other related sequences
that may not have shown up in the direct
search and then we're going to do a
second demo about
unusual organisms to show where you can
start at ncbi taxonomy hub
in order to browse data sets and get
meaningful information
about your genes of interest all right
so it's good to establish
what types of records can be found at
ncbi
most of what we have is submitted so
the audience you guys are submitting
your sequences
as you go through your research programs
and
it's uh there's a lot of sequence in the
database now several petabytes of data
of sequence submissions that are either
coming in through
genbank the european nucleotide archive
or the dna
data bank of japan so they
they share the resources of what is
being submitted by the researchers
and then also we have something called
the sequence read archive
that holds all the raw next-gen
sequencing data
so there is a difference between stuff
that is
submitted and stuff that is curated so
you may have heard of rough seek
really what that means is ncbi itself uh
the researchers and
and uh educators behind the scenes have
taken
the records that have been submitted and
curated quite a few of them
and then put them back out into the
record database with a link back to the
original submission
so that you can have confidence in what
you're looking at as being
you know a good definition of a gene or
a protein boundary
and things like that so those tend to be
a little higher quality or more reliable
um but there's a lot more to it than
that
we have literature databases such as
pubmed
there's other types of molecular
databases like for example variants
dbgap
there's uh population sets or
geo data sets as well and we have
webinars on all of these topics so
please you know feel free to look
through our youtube channel
to find more detail on all the other
databases
but the two places i'm going to
concentrate on today within our
entree system which is what is called
like our large collection of databases
are two central hubs gene
and taxonomy so i'm going to show you
what
gene and taxonomy look like when you
need to get information on a research
organism
so this is the front page of jean and i
could have gotten there
you know through entree or there's a url
here at the top of the page
so you can come into gene and i like
going to the front page
to point out to people there's a lot of
helpful information such as
guides on how to use jeans so there's a
gene quick start over there on the left
there's also download options you can
get on a mailing list
there's all kinds of things you can do
from the front page
but it also defines what kinds of
records you're going to find here
so that's the first data hub the second
data hub we're going to spend a little
time
in in our demos is called taxonomy and
as you can see it also has a quick start
guide
and it has a different sets of data that
it provides
it's organized by the classification of
all the organisms
in the public sequence database so a
natural place to start if you're not
working on human or mouse
all right and then the third thing this
is a slightly newer
uh interact active browser set it's
called data set
it's in beta testing as you can see the
little yellow sticker
up here beta testing um i don't know if
you can see my
cursor but uh anyway it's a rapidly
growing database
uh right now it's limited mainly to
eukaryotes and reference sequence
genomes but also
sars you know covid is a big deal so
they've added that
and there's always announcements
happening about what's available now in
datasets so
you may see a twitter link like the one
i've
taken a screenshot of here where it says
there's more annotations now so it's a
good place to go if you're looking for
annotated gene data sets for organisms
that are
you know not your typical model
organisms and as you can see last
year in may there was one for uh that
included some killer whales bumblebee
starfish etc so it's a great
little uh feed to follow in order to see
what's new
okay um and then of course uh if your
gene is not found but uh you know like
if there isn't like an annotated g set
there's ways to get there
using a couple tools so um we do have
blasts i think most
people who think of ncbi think of blast
first
it allows you to compare sequences
across the entire database
so it's quite a handy tool and then of
course we also have primer blast now so
if you have an organism that you're
researching and you're collecting
samples you would probably want to take
advantage of the ability to design
primers
from very similar organisms that have
genes of interest so we're going to walk
through that as well
so i'm about to transition to the two
demonstrations the first one lasts
about 10 to 15 minutes the second one is
a little bit shorter but
be happy to stick around and answer
questions after
the first demo is looking for a gene of
interest myoglobin in wales
and what we're going to do is get a set
of sequences from the gene data hub
that i showed you we're going to
download those sequences from data sets
and then we're going to use the
sequences we downloaded to make a set of
primers
and then we're going to go back to the
original
gene search and try to expand it by
doing a blast on one specific whale
and then in demo two we're gonna start
in the taxonomy data
hub i'm just gonna show you guys a
little bit you can also get
jellyfish sequences from datasets we're
going to do some blasting there but in a
different way
slightly different way just to show you
that that's available and then we can
show you how you can annotate a gene of
interest
all right what is myoglobin so i've said
it a few times in this presentation
it's a oxygen storm protein in mammal's
muscles
so when whales and seals and dolphins
need to hold their breath
not all the oxygen is carried in their
lungs they can pack a large amount of
oxygen
into their muscles which increases the
amount of time they can spend
underwater and this is a you know an
area of
scientific fascination there's lots of
papers about it i have just a little
note over here about a publication on
a beaked whale that set a four hour long
dive record which is the longest known
incidence of a whale holding its breath
underwater and it was a baked whale
so that's a particular type of whale um
that has to do with the shape of its its
face so
um yeah so that was really interesting
so this is an area of active research
so there are there is data available
to find and then the demo two that i'm
going to work on
is looking for jellyfish so what if
you know i'm not working with what we
like to call as invertebrate people the
charismatic megafauna the big guys
where do i go to find my data so there's
going to be a second approach
looking at the available data using ncbi
taxonomy
and then we're going to look for some
conserved genes in an assembly that is
not annotated
and the organism i chose for this demo
is called santa riya maliensis
it's a very cool looking uh true
jellyfish i mean it's a skyphone
and so uh i'm going to now go into the
demos and show you guys what's going on
all right so demo one
i land on the gene page and i want to
know what informations they have for
whale
and my gene of interest myoglobin
and when i pull it up i'm going to see
that i got 15 results okay
but the first thing you might want to do
is make sure that
your search as you can see here i had to
capitalize
and that's the quirky thing about ncbi
you want to make sure your search gives
you what you're looking for and it's not
accidentally stumbling upon something
that may be named whale but not
actually whale so if you scroll down
here you'll see that
yes these first few ones are definitely
what we would consider whale to be whale
or dolphin
but when i get down here i see whale
shark so whale sharks not a true whale
it's a fish and also
i got a bacteria and it just means that
whale was too broad of a term
because it looked for whale
over here if you look in the search box
over here to the right where i'm
highlighting
it looked for whale in all the fields so
basically
each record has a title
and a description and it has actual the
authors who provided the record
and if one of those fields also contains
the word whale
it may accidentally show up in this
field um
so there's a few different uh ways to
correct this there's a taxonomic
grouping up here so i could simply just
click on mammals to get rid of the fish
and the bacteria and that would give me
my whale list
or there's another way to correct this i
could um
so that was up here you guys can see my
cursor
or in the search detail box i could get
rid of
whale in all fields right there and then
resubmit the search
or what you need to know um and one
thing i was reminded of as i was
prepping this presentation is if you
just put
the plural version of what you're
looking for so
whales instead of whale
and i rerun the search it actually gives
me just
wales and you'll see that the gene page
the results page has changed slightly so
now you see
the taxonomic you know name
is cetacea which holds the whale
whale groups and so you'll see over here
that the search box has been altered
to be correct and now my taxonomic
grouping is only whales and dolphins
so that's just something to be aware of
if you're not
really familiar with gene or how to
search for organisms
and then i just want to quickly say up
here if you get really lost
you know you can choose to add
you know qualifying things here like
organism
you know this is another place i could
have put whales that was in the advanced
search drop down which is up here okay
and it's as you could saw like when i
went over there it saved all my previous
searches
right okay
so now i have a good data set what can i
do with it like where am i going to head
with this data set to actually get these
sequences and so this is where i'm going
to highlight
our new uh interactive website that
allows you to download
easily called data sets but in order to
do that i need to get
this table um this would be really hard
to just kind of copy paste
over it it has like special figures and
check boxes but luckily
if you look down here at the bottom and
click on tabular
you can just get a list of the unique
identifiers so these are the records
that are identified in that table
and so i'm copying i'm just copying
those records so you can get a table
you get a summary you can get all kinds
of things but the easiest way to go from
here
into the next section of ncbi i'm going
to show you is by copying that
and now i'm going to go over to data
sets and use that information
so here is datasets so i think it's a
very beautiful website i love
seeing the pictures of the organisms i
got up there
and just to quickly show you um you can
get genomes from going to data sets you
don't have to go through the regular
ncbi interface
and you know it's a great way to kind of
pull up
whales here if you want the whole genome
so that's a lot of records like i
like i started out this um you know
demonstration i only want
one gene you know from whale so here
they've actually got it broken down into
more
you know things but it's cetacea so i
could
find out uh what genomes are new
and interesting so we've got some beluga
whales
uh you know we've got gray whales things
like that and then
there's some genomes that are
categorized as reference meaning they're
a little bit more annotated than uh
what's been submitted
but this is cool to know about if you
want the whole entire genome but
we came over to data sets actually to
use those unique identifiers
so i'm going to go back to the front
page on that come on
here we go and i'm just going to scroll
down a little bit so here's the front
page
i'm scrolling down it's right here get
started
blender get started i'm going to enter
my identifiers manually i could have had
a file
but there's only 12 it was easy to copy
paste them and so when i open it up
you'll see oh
the information i got from the part of
the database called gene
that's the first option so i'm going to
copy and paste that but there's other
options here
i could do gene symbol accession number
but um i had copied that from that table
so i'm going to add that
and boom there we go there's the
sequence information that i can download
as a table or a set of fasta files
and what's cool about this for those of
you who've spent a lot of time on ncbi
is i don't have to go to the protein
page get the proteins then i don't have
to go over to the
nucleotide page to get the nucleotides
they're all here
and you can get to them you can see them
by switching transcript view
here but um another cool thing you can
do is add more information if you want
the table like if you're not actually
going to get the sequences you just want
the table you can
you cannot get the table to be
a little more complete you can add
common name for example
right so killer whales orca over here
um another thing to notice is we're in
gene view
and it shows that there's two entries
for
uh orca so there's more than one gene
view
so i'm not sure if that means there's
paralogs or stuff like that but that's
kind of cool too
and you'll see there's two different
links here so there's
1099 and 1162.
so i may only just want one uh
sequence for each organism so
maybe i'll switch over to transcript
view which instead of having it
you know here you had to click here to
open it but when i switch to transcript
view it gives me both versions
right of every uh transcript that leads
to the gene of interest
and so maybe i only want the longest one
so that's one of the columns that i've
selected to open
so i select all by clicking on this
check box here
but now i'm going to go back and
unselect anything
that is the shortest version of the gene
so here monodon has two versions there's
671 and 744 i'm unchecking
671 globocephala also
unchecking 1061 and then oh there's one
more here
um okay great and so now
i'm ready to download so this is where i
can go here download and i could just
get the table
but i really want the data set i really
want the fast day
and i just really like this a lot
because it pulls up
genes transcripts and proteins all at
one place and so i can call it uh
whales myoglobin
okay and longest okay
and then it's gonna download and here
i'm just gonna make a little note
because it is in beta
um it's going to if you're in chrome
it will actually download a zip file
don't be surprised if you're in safari
or
firefox it may not work uh so just
switch browsers if it doesn't actually
download a file
and then um i'm having a little issue
with unzipping so i already had unzipped
it
on my computer so i could show you guys
what kind of uh
information you get so sorry i'm just
gonna switch
over to here real quick so um this was
the zipped file i unzipped it
and when i open it you can see uh
it may change the name of your folder to
ncbi dataset so that's something to be
aware of so if you're doing this a lot
make sure to rename your folders to keep
old data sets
and then under here it's going to have
my protein fasta
and my rna fasta here
and so the rna fasta is what i'm going
to use next
in the demonstration because i'm going
to take this information i downloaded
from datasets
and i'm going to go over and get some
primers going
so here's the fasta file
and i'm just going to it's small enough
that i don't have to
use it as a file i'm just going to copy
and paste for this demo
but you could do files and now i'm going
to go to the next website i'm going to
demonstrate which is called primer blast
and all these
links can be found in the slides um
but also it's really easy to google for
these things you can just google primer
blast ncbi
it'll bring you right here to this
website so now
there's two things you need to do you
need to
switch this tab here so
this is a one template so if i only have
one sequence to enter into the box
i would use this tab but i really need
to switch it because i've got multiple
sequences
and then i'm going to click on this
right and it's going to load
and from copy paste all right like i
said i could have chosen a file
um that's that's one is switching the
tab
and then two is i i'm working on whales
i don't really want to
see human primer set so i would come
down here maybe and change this
organism and you'll see like if you
start cruising around ncbi a lot
this box to choose your organism is
everywhere so like take advantage of
that when you're working on a non-model
organism set the search parameters to be
just your organism of interest don't let
it search the entire databases because
then you'll be frustrated by
a lot of uh searches that go off to
human or
nice here's another place like you can
make changes
like there are drop down boxes at the
bottom
[Music]
but uh we're ready to go so i'm gonna
click get primers
and it takes a couple minutes to run
come on
running why isn't it running
i'm afraid this would happen but that's
okay because i already saved the results
elsewhere it works believe me it works
it's just
of course it's not going to work while
i'm sitting here but i did save the
results so basically
uh what you're going to see when you
design the primers against a bunch of
templates it's going to give you more
than one option
but what it did is it took the
accessions that i entered those fasta
files it stacked them up all against
each other
and then it designed the primers up here
and so you can
pick a primer set that
increases the probability of observing
the portion of the gene that's of
interest
so if you look at a lot of these uh you
know
sequences compared to each other you'll
notice that
they are different just in certain areas
so you can kind of see these red
spots here so maybe you only care about
protein changes
that happen in this particular region so
you'd want to put like maybe primer set
or maybe you care about gene changes
over here
in this particular region you'd pick one
of these primer sets
right and then down below uh you know
things like melt
and you know statistics and stuff like
that have a lot to do with how you run
the pcr in your thermocycler
so all the details are down here so that
you can
get the best result when you do actually
use
one of these primers as a template okay
all right so that's a primer blast which
is kind of a special
way to use data but now i'm going to go
back and point out something about the
original
data set that we were looking at so
i have to reverse back okay so when we
were looking at data sets
i might want to look for other sequences
that are not
reference sequences that are like little
less annotated that may have just been
submitted recently
um or don't you know haven't been
identified as myoglobin necessarily or
just are predicted
something to notice here is that there's
one sequence here that's
different than the others in this list
and what it is
is the sperm whale has an accession
number that begins with the extra
special
n when you see an n that's actually
really good news that means there's been
some extra work
done to validate that this is the
gene that we think it is and so um an
x is a predicted protein even though
there may have been some work to
validate it with some rna-seq and things
like that it's more
in silico prediction versus like a study
that actually validated so i just want
to open this up
to show the difference here so um
somebody was
you know using there's several different
journals that
um you know talk about this particular
sequence
that are showing how they validated
it so you know they did some
crystallography crystal structure
you know they've done other things to
prove that this is the protein that we
think it is
so this is a great sequence to choose if
you're going to do some more blasting
for related sequences that aren't
necessarily in the refseq database
so um i went over to the record here i
can run blast directly from here
i could just grab the accession number
you know to go to blast
there's many different ways to do it so
if i go to the front page of blast it'll
give me a few choices
so it is a nucleotide sequence so i'm
probably going to do a nucleotide to
nucleotide
thing later on we're going to do a
protein to nucleid
us nucleotide search so that's going to
be t blasting but today
right now at this time we're doing
nucleotides so i can just
enter that accession number so it's the
sperm whale version of myoglobin
okay so as you can see i've been running
glass and practicing for this so it um
recognizes my organism but it would say
human probably here for you guys so what
you would want to do is to change it
to whales you know you can just start
typing in
whales you could put in uh cetacea
right um the taxonomic id won't change
so it's always 9721 whether i put in
whales or cetaceans
it's really this is like the number that
blast is using to kind of
limit the amount of search and then down
here i
i want to kind of look for things that
may not be annotated very well so i'm
going to just say
somewhat similar blast and so that's
like a little bit um
you know looser and then another thing i
like to show people who work on
non-model stuff
is that you don't have to just go with a
hundred hits you could increase the
amount of hits you get
and your blast search like i could up it
to 250
if i wanted um because the more
distantly related
organisms that have just changed enough
may not get a high hit value but they
may be
in there so by kind of increasing the
number of hits you get that it maximizes
your chance of finding interesting stuff
so i've set it up i'm going to click
blast so please work this time okay good
so my blast is running um
and it takes a couple minutes not
terrible
so we'll just let it run so you guys can
breathe okay great boom
so here is uh my list
and so it keeps my recent searches
uh you know for a few days right it
keeps it until
um the 12th uh so that's not too bad so
like if you want to come back like the
next day and keep working from a place
that you left off of
you can use this little link here recent
results and come back to these results
but as i scroll down you're going to see
now
this list of organisms that we can see
and i can pull up common names again so
we can see
are a little different than the list
that we started with it has
added species by doing a regular blast
and you can see here that some of these
are just submit
submitted sequences coming in from all
over the world you know once again like
europe and
japan and and us are the main three
uh you know accession number types
you'll see
and um it's in our database so now we
have a much
longer list of interesting sequences but
there's a few things instead of just
plain old downloading right like i could
just grab the sequences i could select
all the sequences and then i could just
download them
um here using download you know
um there's things you can do
interactively
so i want to look at maybe how closely
related
some of these things are so i could
either use taxonomy
right so taxonomy the tab up here opens
up
the list of things that that got a hit
um and then i could go to just like i
could be like oh i really care about
this particular species i can go just
directly to that hit
by navigating through the text sonomy
tab um let's see so if i go back to
descriptions
i also see there's options here to
generate some distance trees so like if
i use
distance tree up here it grabs
everything but maybe i only want things
that uh have really high coverage right
so i want to make sure that it's a
decent chance of it being the thing that
i think it is and i also want it to be
kind of long
so i just arbitrarily said i'm going to
get rid of i'm going to uncheck
the species that have a slightly lower
coverage
and let's see and
are slightly shorter here
and then i'm going to generate a
distance tree of results and so this
isn't like a
true uh phylogenetic you know
analysis tool but what it does is it um
kind of just
organizes your findings you can just get
a quick glance like what's going
on so here you can see that things are
um like this is the uh
pygmy sperm whale and then here's sperm
whale so those are kind of outliers
and then peter cooper who's also on the
call showed me this cool way to
you know make it look a little more
interesting if you go over here to tools
there's different layouts you can choose
such as a radial tree that kind of
boom like spreads out the species name
so it's a little easier to read
i'm like who's with who
and so you know we have the baleanoptera
down here and like we have
now we have the pygmy sperm whale kind
of closer
you know branching off of sperm whale
right and then something very
interesting if you recall like forever
ago when i brought up about that article
these are beaked whales so the beaked
whale that was in that article was
called ziphius
um i guess there's not a sequence that
showed up in genbank for that yet
you know it was a more of a nature study
it wasn't really a molecular study so
that
the sequence may not be available yet or
maybe it's private not submitted
but you can see that other beaked whales
kind of branch off by themselves as well
so sperm whales have a kind of a
slightly different myoglobin
and apparently maybe quails do too so
this is just kind of a cool
way to confirm uh you know
your your viewpoint like uh before you
keep going and you know is this
interesting
so yes you definitely would probably
want to download these sequences and
maybe do some
you know there's some duplicates once
again um you know maybe you would screen
for different things
and then we're not really going to talk
about it today but you can
do alignments um like here this is
uh the alignments against the query
sequence
but um alignments here if that's
something you may be familiar with it's
more like a muscle or a cluster w
but it's it's it's it's just a quick and
dirty version and like we're not going
to spend a lot of time here but i just
want to show you that that's an option
um it can it can line up and show you
where your sequences are different from
each other
okay all right so that was demo number
one
um let me just bring back up a
powerpoint
so that was demo number one we talked
about the beaked whale
now i'm gonna move into demo number two
which is a little shorter of a demo
okay great so just to remind you this is
a going to be an organism that doesn't
have a lot of annotated
uh sets in the ncbi except for a few
particular species like if you're
working on corals
there's a lot of annotation available so
that's a good place to start if you're
looking for jeans
um but if you if you want to work on um
jellyfish there may not be as many
uh locations to get that information so
let's
go the other route of getting
information for my research organisms so
here i am at the starting point called
taxonomy
um and you can just get here by googling
ncbi tax on
sorry my dog's barking and so here we
are in taxonomy and i might want to
start by going well i want to work on
jellyfish
so what i've learned is it's better to
put the plural
version a name common name in
and it's interesting it actually uh
brings us to the
um sky fazoa so
it brings me to skype is oh which is the
class of true jellyfishes because there
are other things called jellyfish that
aren't
true jellyfishes and if i click on that
distinction it's actually going to show
me
um the uh all the families
and genus of species that are entered
into
genbank right so there's a lot of
information
on jellyfishes um
in skyphozoa right like if i wanted to
go see the uh
cubisons i might want to go back up to
nigeria
right so cubazoa are where i believe our
portuguese man of war and stinging
things are but um you know you can jump
around
using this uh classification system
that's at the top here but i want to go
back to skype
okay great so i'm here and um
i want to find out how much information
is there about jellyfish so
you may notice this little grayed out
box up here it has
all the different kinds of data that are
carried inside ncbi
but the most interesting data sets to
start with usually are nucleotide gene
protein you might want to know about raw
data sequencing experiments and then of
course
genome assemblies even if they're rough
like
it's good to see a genome assembly see
if something new has been entered
so you can click these boxes and then
just go
here go and when you click on that
you'll see
these numbers are showing up to the
right
of the classification so for all
jellyfish there are
um 12 assemblies available there's
143 genes that's not a lot
but there's a lot of nucleotides and
proteins
and sra experiments so that's where you
go for raw data
that may not have been assembled well um
but you can still find data in there
especially now that we're getting long
read sequences right so
that kind of reduces some of the
confusion of finding bits and pieces of
things
so i thought an interesting case study
would be
um a jellyfish here santeria
that does have an assembly so there is
one assembly
and then there's 22 sra data sets but as
you can see there's not been a lot of
annotation done
because nucleotide and protein are very
low numbers right for what you'd expect
for something with a genome assembly
so if i click on that number one so i
just clicked on the number one
next to santeria it opens up that
assembly
right and it gives me a lot of options i
can't get directly from the blast page
so i can run a blast here
i can run a plymouth primer blast that's
specific
just to this genome assembly so we're
going to do that right now
we're going to blast the assembly and
let me just show you how this looks a
slightly different
so the blast page here um
doesn't have as many options you don't
get a protein blast
right because we're talking about
genomic stuff
i'm just going to close the warning um
and uh it automatically
picks the database for you so there's no
organism
like box or anything like that you're
just going to be blasting directly
against the assembly
okay so it limits the size of what you
have to do
so i'm just going to go over here and
get the um example
gene so this is a housekeeping gene
called
cdc20 and this is also in gene like when
i
uh plugged in this name here let me just
show you how i got here
i thought it would be an interesting
example so like here
if i go to cdc 20 um it doesn't show me
all that
to begin with but if i you know click on
one of the links
it it gives me this full um
full record so a full record for a gene
tells you a lot about it it gives you
literature
it gives you rna by tissue and so this
is generally something you'll find for
human stuff but it doesn't mean it
wouldn't hurt you know wouldn't help in
your search for meaningful genes or
which tissues to look in right because
it's something in the brain it might be
in the brain
what you're looking at um so you know
and it maps out
what your expected exons and introns
should look like for this particular
gene if you are successful in locating
it
right so there's a lot of information
about cdc
20 which is a part of um
it's a regulatory protein that's used at
several points
in the cell cycle um it requires
uh two microtubule dependent processes
etc etc it's
a very good check to make sure perhaps
like is this a good genome assembly
right it's a
eukaryote that goes through this process
the cell cycle process
this gene should be in there great
so i just grabbed the um
accession number actually uh i'm more
likely to get hit if i use the protein
and then i do a translate translated
last
search so i'm just going to go over here
and copy the uh
protein okay so when you're doing a
search nucleotide to nucleotide is a
one-to-one
right but uh protein can be translated
six
different ways so you get you know six
times the
options to find it in a genome
especially one that hasn't been
annotated yet
great so that's why i'm using t blasting
it's a translated blast search
for a protein and now it's going to
search the assembly
to see if this protein is somewhere in
the genome assembly
and the blast results here will look
different because it's not going to have
annotation except for the blast
result so um the quickest way to get to
the answer whether this is in here is
like
to look at um the alignments
page so you should have seen these types
of things before so it is showing oh
you know we did find a lot of homology
uh between that
gene right and it's in a lot of a lot of
hits within the same
contig here so when you see a range like
this
this is like where in the content part
of what we
blasted against landed but a
way to organize the information so you
get to the right thing right away
is to go here to this box and sort by
query start position
which then brings up the query that
starts closest to the beginning
because if you click on the graphics
here
it's going to show you this really long
contig with the teeny tiny little hits
of things
but this will help me organize and pick
one
that starts close to where my query
started right my
query position six um see but it starts
at a
position 1.4 million like inside the
content so this
clicking on this gen bank versus this
genbank is going to take me directly
there
to view it and so this will just take a
second
oh i meant to click graphics i hit the
wrong thing
um graphics i meant to hit say graphics
there
the last two times okay so i want to
look at the
graphics but also the genbank you know
brings me to the part that i care about
in that contig
okay so i zoomed in on just the first
part of where the hit
is but by zooming out
here i can kind of see
that this uh protein i used as a model
recovered hits that seemed to
recapitulate
the exons that i'd expect to see
they're you know they're slightly fuzzy
here and
they're all the exons are there so this
is a great way to view
um the quality of your assembly and also
to get started
on finding genes of interest in your
organism
and that's it that's all i was going to
talk about i mean there's
other things just really quickly you can
you know you can
zoom in here and it gives you a bunch of
options of what you can do with just
that
range right so now we've located where
it is in the genome but it's in this
really long contig
so you know we could go to the range um
we could blast search on just the piece
that i've got highlighted in green
i could do a primer blast or i could
just get the fasta
and then maybe use that as a search tool
for other jellyfish that had information
for them
so i think that's where i'm going to
wrap it up i've been talking a lot
i'd like to hear from the group about
their questions
so let's go thanks emily okay so
there's lots of sort of very there's
some pretty specific questions that i
don't know that everybody is interested
in the answer
one of them that i thought adelaide you
might be has some input on because i
don't really
know one person asked about
annotating um like this so they have
fast day sequences and they want to
annotate them
we do have a prokaryotic annotation
pipeline that is portable and you can
set up but i don't really know what
people do
out in the world who don't have access
to a eukaryotic genome annotation
pipeline do you have any thoughts about
what kind of
things would be available to people for
free because he's interested in a free
thing
yeah there's a um a couple open source
genome browsers
right that you can um build i believe
ucsc has
one where you can annotate or you can do
annotations
you have to know command line for that
one but there's one called j browse
i believe that you can um you can use
there's there's
i would just do uh like a google search
for um
genome browsers like free genome
browsers because a lot of those are
open source tools and there's even
websites that you can go to
and load your genome of interest so ucsc
lets you do that
um it's complicated but you can like
there's ways to
upload your uh genome of interest or
pick one that's already been done so
there is a link over from ncbi and then
you can
save your annotations as files there
yeah you can annotate for yourself and
save the annotations you don't publish
them there but
um that would be like where you could
you know when you
when you publish your um these people
here like didn't annotate the genome
because they were using it for something
different
but many people do end up coming back
and publishing
you know their findings and that becomes
records in ncbi
yeah okay another question that well i
mean i'm sorry a comment from
one of the people in the in the question
spot uh
someone mentioned an algorithm called
augustus are you familiar with that one
that's related to the question oh yeah
yeah i know yeah i'm pretty sure that's
free
so yeah i'll give you a file that'll
give you some output with some genome
coordinates
that give you its best best hits uh
yeah so that's called augustus like the
emperor
um a couple of other questions that were
that i think i'll address if you don't
mind um
one of the things that people asked
several times in the chat was about how
to find
their particular type of sequence and
and and one of the things that adelaide
pointed out is that if you have a
particular organism in mind
you know use that organism's name
followed by
the word organism in square brackets and
you will get all the data for that
organism
other one or you can also go to taxonomy
to do that
and then whatever particular gene or
sequence you're interested in then
you know add that name to the end of
your search
and you know you'll get what you get
when you go into the nucleotide database
or into the protein database um
here's here's something i do like i'll
go to the main
entree gene page and i'll look at all
the databases and so maybe i care about
porcupines
um and i'll put organism here like peter
suggested
i don't know could be one or not we can
try it it might be yeah why not
yeah so it didn't work but uh you know
maybe what else could i use here
so you can try try searching porcupines
in taxonomy and see what it does because
sometimes it's helpful
like saying you see if that works
you know it may so change that yeah
but that's sometimes is i'm using common
names like but like
yeah like peter's pointing out sometimes
it works better
if you got anything so there there are a
bunch of
so there is there actually is a there's
one there's a family
there are two different families of
rodents that are porcupines there's new
world in old world and so
you'd have to know which one you were
interested in but if you knew that
right then you could go there and do
that kind of thing to get your
i mean if you click on that of course
then you'll get that table
of all the data oh yeah that's a good
point we should point out the table over
here
yeah and so then you can then if you say
you want to get all the nucleotide
sequences for this
family then you could simply click over
there to get them
and then you know if you wanted to add
something so suppose you're interested
in a particular gene in here
you can just you know write the word the
boolean operator
and at the top
whatever you want to do you know
whatever gene might be in here
who knows you'd have to look and see you
know this is a good example of a group
of organisms that's largely been
probably explored for taxonomy purposes
or for
you know for doing phylogenetics on or
something like that so you're going to
see a lot of marker sequences probably
okay cool other questions well there are
there's a bunch in here that i don't
think that i have answered somewhat and
we're kind of out of time so what i
think we should probably do is to is to
wrap it up
and i don't know if you had that slide
at the end that has the sort of the help
document stuff
but we could just throw that up here and
what i'll do
we'll answer these questions and make
the document available
so just by just to mention a couple of
things here
you know if you want to keep up with
what's going on at ncbi
and um we have a blog called ncbi
insights
we also have a number of fact sheets for
different resources that are available
on the um
on our ftp site so go there and to find
out about those
and also our youtube channel so if you
just google ncbi youtube you'll find the
channel
we're moving that stuff over to the nlm
youtube channel so you might want to
check there too
so thanks everybody thank you and thanks
ali for that presentation that was very
nice
so bye everybody and we'll see you next
time
you